being from screwed up click and i kind
of feel like you were a little bit ahead
slightly ahead
of the of the of the kind of like
h-town
national craze i kind of feel like you
were like probably the first dude in
that class of right like of your peers
that really popped correct
i'm talking like obviously you know the
chamillionaires of paul walsh you were
kind of first i was first yeah i was i
was the first person like out of
that wave you know we had la troye he
went platinum right but i just mean in
terms of just the ti i feel like the age
racket yeah
yeah yeah but i was just saying you know
we had chocolates
yeah we had that like right before like
the the
[ __ ] started going on you know but um
yeah yeah definitely i was i was first
was there ever any uh
was there ever any like because swisher
house had kind of you know uh michael
5000 watts was
chopping and screwing [ __ ] as well was
there ever any sort of static between
the screwed up [ __ ] and the swisher
house [ __ ] it was
well and it like because obviously
everyone ends up on that source cover
right which was a crazy cover right
right the the don't mess with texas
everybody and their mom was on that
cover right um but uh did that like like
like what was what was like your take on
like seeing swisher house come out and
kind of obviously you know dj screw
started chopping and screwing [ __ ] but
it also was like a houston thing as much
as it was his thing that he created you
know um
but what what was your take on the
swisher house movement you know kind of
being on the other side of things
i'm in a screwed up click so
like
i'm an understandable person you know i
mean so a lot of members was like oh
[ __ ] what is that what's going on
they're doing what we doing and my whole
take i just feel like hey man we
inspired some people to to do what they
do you know i mean so i didn't look at
it
you know like some of the other members
looked at it you know you had some
people that was like they didn't like it
and you had some people that was like
hey man [ __ ]
they expressing their self they they
wanna you know what i mean we motivated
some people to you know what i mean so
that's how i always looked at it and
that's one of the reasons i'm the first
person
out the screwed up click to go do a
freestyle on the swisher house
so i got clap my biggest freestyle
is on a swisher house tape which
freestyle was that it's uh it's a
mixtape kyle i-45 and um
um it's a record like we blow in though
i might be on jay leno they be like flip
can you listen to my demo i say nah
[ __ ] i got shows to do after the
concert i got hoes to screw like that's
a classic freestyle best like
[ __ ] scream that [ __ ] like word
for word and um so i was always going
over there i got family that's on the
north side so
in the midst of the north side and south
side beef i was always on enough side
anyway like
because i don't i don't at the end of
the day the way i feel we houston right
i mean at the end of the day it's about
unity for me so
you know yeah my biggest freestyle is on
the swiss yardstick that's crazy and i'm
in a screwed up clip